soir simon garneau merci d'être avec
nous on imagine effectivement que c'est
une première victoire comme l'a dit et
monaco dès lors vous devez être
satisfait de ce rejet de la cour d'appel
de paris
oui bonsoir oui nous sommes très heureux
un premier pas vers la condamnation
aussi des gens donc c'est une bonne
nouvelle
le prononcé avec précaution marcel
encore beaucoup travailler du travail à
faire en tout cas ce que vous espérez
c'est certainement une condamnation et
un procès au pénal c'est aussi l'enjeu
de ce rejet il y aura bel et bien un
procès au pénal de de société lubrizol
il ya assez d'éléments qui démontrent
les dirigeants de cette usine avait tous
les éléments pour pouvoir éviter cette
catastrophe sanitaire et environnement
sauf qu'ils n'ont rien fait vous avez
les informations de la part des services
de la part de leur assureur
il les avait plus et donc oui sont
pénalement il va falloir tirer le
responsable alors il ya eu des
négligences flagrante de la part de
l'entreprise selon vous est-ce que
c'était une négligence coupable ou ou
une négligence ma foi d'inattention est
ce que ce que je veux dire par là
pardonnez moi c est ce que il y a de la
volonté il y avait un acte volontaire en
tout cas on a laissé faire malgré wii
est beaucoup trop de dysfonctionnements
déjà lorsqu'on envoie de pompiers sur le
lieu et qu'il n'y a aucun moyen pour il
je sais si c'est inadmissible donc c'est
plein d'éléments comme ça qui font que
le danger est l'arrivée donc il le
savait très bien
donc si on veut que les choses ou genre
en france si on veut vraiment que les
entreprises respectent l'environnement
et notre santé nous est brun capitaux
justement il va falloir mener des
dossiers au pénal
ont pas hésité à construire des dossiers
juridiques et a monté les collectifs et
des associations pour aller au pénal et
à l'ailé traduits en justice
ce qui retient l'attention sinon le
cavallo c'est que cette mise en examen
elle est sûre les dégâts
environnementaux mais mais pas sur la
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui est ce
que ce qualificatif manque selon vous
clairement
bien évidemment ce sera nous prouver ce
avait fait face au danger qui est
impossible parce que l'on parle de deux
cancers de maladies futures
évidemment à l'instant ping immédiate
mais on peut pas se satisfaire de ça on
sait très bien que va y avoir des
maladies donc ça va arriver dans
quelques années
donc il faut se préparer nous c'est que
cette catastrophe sanitaire qui va
arriver
nous espérons que le juge d'entendre a
ainsi façon nous sommes partis pour une
longue procédure
donc nous croisons les doigts pour
éviter des morts de la catastrophe
sanitaire mais il faut s'y préparer
vu des substances qui on peut les ai vu
le tonnage aussi est autant
d'expositions père en fils d'arnold fait
face à des odeurs chimiques des
problèmes de santé liés à cette usine
donc à la décontamination de sceptiques
donc il y aura forcément des séquelles
sur leur santé et toute façon notre
environnement et notre santé
ce que l'on mange ce que l'on boit donc
s'il ya une atteinte à l'environnement
il ya forcément une intervention donc
nous nous en tant qu'association
victimes
à nous aussi d'apporter les éléments au
juge les caches cas est particulier les
avons tous des problèmes de santé
différent
il ya des rapports qui commencent à
émerger
mais c'est un peu trop timides ont fait
appel aux médecins spécialistes afin
qu'ils s'organisent aussi faim qu'on
soit pas seulement qu'ils aident les
associations victims il montre notre
collègue secrétaire de l'union des
victimes de lubrizol christophe on le
vit
il appelle carrément à faire changer les
lois et il dit depuis napoléon on
protège de la chimie tant qu'il n'y aura
pas de vraie sanction comme des
fermetures administratives et bien les
accidents industriels se multiplieront à
vous partager ce diagnostic
alors évidemment que dans cette affaire
il ya le droit de l'environnement
mais quinze mille euros damende pour une
entreprise comme lubrizol c'est comme si
vous vous étiez au volant de votre
voiture que vous griller un feu rouge et
que la police mais qu un centime d'euros
d'amendé ce que vous pensez que la
prochaine fois que vous êtes précise et
une en france
vous allez peut-être pas hésité grillé
le feu rouge 15 centimes d'euros
d'amendé bien que c'est pas suffisant
donc pour ces entreprises c'est pareil
c'est insuffisant pour le pénal par
contre là si on commence à prendre la
responsabilité individuelle ses
dirigeants n'a peut-être qu'on pourra
faire changer les choses mais il est
clair que il ya un vide juridique at il
est clair que les entreprises les
officiels ofit polluent à tout va
vraiment ils préfèrent pollué que de
mettre aux normes que deux rendez compte
que pour le moment cette usine à la
toucher une prime d'assurance de 91
millions d'euros
pendant que nous victimes on n'a même
pas on n'a rien perçu a dû avancer de
l'argent on a dû le payer nos
traitements payer les franchises
d'assurances etc etc
et puis le tranquille 91 millions
d'euros
et c'est sûrement qu'un premier
versement donc vraiment me demande pas
une incitation à la pollution
il faut vraiment que l'état veille et
que nous citoyens weill antilles il faut
agir
je vous découvre qu'à vélo c'était ma
prochaine question il ya la justice bien
sûr le recours à la justice que vous
êtes en train de faire mais enfin vu la
gravité de la situation à ce que vous en
avait appelé aux pouvoirs publics aux
autorités et si oui que vous vous at on
répondu
comme d'habitude un agence régionale de
santé santé publique france sont les
grands absents vous rendez compte que
nous sommes dans une attente d'un suivi
sanitaire et que juste pour et pour
rendre publique une enquête
10 faction sur le ressenti de la
catastrophe on doit l'attendre et nous
l'attendons toujours
donc soit 10 ans et doit sortir mais
voyons l'urgence où est l'urgence c'est
pourquoi nous en tant que associations
on souhaite en place un institut est
possible comme il en existe à
fos-sur-mer un institut indépendant qui
sera géré par des citoyens afin
d'éveiller et d'agir rapidement
lorsqu'il y aura une catastrophe comme
il y en a trop souvent
merci beaucoup simon de carvalho d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt française